Hi everyone.
Thank you all for coming to today's
fireside chat with Craig Newmark.
This event is part of a talks at Google
program and today's fireside chat is
hosted by in a Google internal
community called Wikipedians at Google.
Thank you for all for being here.
My name is Dan and Joe.
Today's jewelry is open ad go cracked
dash dory and I already add some of the
questions from the RSVP.
Please feel free to use that link
to add your questions and vote. Uh,
we are super happy here,
uh,
to have a well renowned intrepreneur
and philanthropist Mr. Crack mark re new
mark,
founder of craigslist and crowd Craig
Newmark Foundation crack is born in 1952
in New Jersey and moved to San Francisco
around 1990 around 1995 he started a
mailing list which ultimately turned into
craiglist.org one of the world's most
successful online classified
advertisement websites. Nowadays,
he focused more on philanthropy efforts
with a crack and new mark foundation and
hasn't been involved in management
since 2000 while he caught himself still
doing some lightweight customer service.
Please welcome Craig
folks. Thanks. And I really
do wear Kangle hats like this,
but it's too warm in here now.
Yeah.
What I'd like to do is speak a
bit about a founding craigslist.
Why I did it,
I'll talk a little bit,
but what about the technology than
I normally do, a given the audience,
I'm going to talk about the philanthropic
philosophy I developed without
consciously thinking about
it along those lines.
And I'm going to talk about the
philanthropy I've engaged with right now,
including connections to
Wikipedia and also to, uh,
something called Google news because
I'm actually highly involved with that.
In fact,
I'll just begin by saying,
so I don't forget that a Google
news folks are doing really good,
really important work,
particularly involving the countering
of disinformation that includes,
uh, trying to get the names right.
Richard Gingras, Steve Grove,
a Erica Anderson and Olivia Ma.
I'm probably missing some names,
but those are the ones that
come to mind immediately.
So I may repeat a little bit
more about that. But, uh,
something I mentioned the head too
is I spent 17 years at IBM and I saw
frequently,
especially in the field,
people were not given
credit for stuff they did.
So I overdo it.
I spent a couple of years of Charles
Schwab for that matter going around the
company at lunch, things telling people
that the Internet would be a thing.
Sunday, this was 94 mostly.
And the guy who started the,
uh,
web at a Charles Schwab,
a guy named Doris Milosky has been a
forgotten except that I keep bringing his
name up at things like this.
Um,
keep track of time for me cause I
don't want to go crazy with it. Uh,
my ideal is that I am a
nerd of the old school, uh,
born in, you know, the early fifties,
grew up through the fifties and sixties.
There's a stereotype about a guy who
wears a plastic pocket protector,
thick black glasses,
taped together and no social skills.
That was me in completely,
literally in high school two times.
I really had my thick black glass is
broken and I tried taping them together
until I got replacements.
No social skills and even now what you
see before you is a simulation of social
skills.
And I can do that for about 90 minutes
after which things start going south and
I become, I become a cranky. Um,
my ideal,
you know,
is that I got a couple of
degrees in computer sciences
at Case Western case tech
in the mid Seventies.
Although I've learned coding in high
school in 1969 using punch cards for Tran
too,
and an IBM 1620.
I feel like I should make it your homework
assignment to look up a all three,
but you'll be frightened.
However,
I can assure you that the 1620 was
from that generation of computers,
which had the blinky lights and they
literally did have the blinky lights and I
kind of miss that. Not that I'm going
to be searching a surplus for, uh,
for one of those,
it was about the size of a player piano.
Anyway, you know, after some
point I decide to leave IBM,
I get myself hired by Charles Schwab
who brings me to San Francisco,
which I appreciate and I got a lot of
help from people around town on the net
using it.
Newsgroups well helping me with
a neighborhoods around town,
helping me with uh, you know,
restaurants and how to get around.
And this was pretty good,
you know,
so early 95 rolls around and I'm
leaving Charles Schwab at the time,
but I'm thinking I should give back.
So I started as simple mailing list and
basically what it is is I'm using a very
advanced email tool back in
[inaudible] 95 called pine.
And you know,
I figure it's just a CC list,
10 12 people to start with events
that involve arts and our technology.
And then I, uh, you know,
just the people tell me about
more stuff and I do more stuff.
People started asking me to do different
things and I go along with that.
But about the middle of a 95,
the CC list stuff at about
250 addresses breaks.
And I need to use a list server,
somebody volunteers, major Domo,
and as an old school,
neuro dime, very literal.
So I'll call it San Francisco events.
People around me that are smarter than me,
they say we already call it craigslist,
keep calling it that it signifies
it will be personal in the quirky.
And then they explained to me
what a brand is. A seriously,
I didn't know those of you,
uh, in marketing. We should
have cause to mark me.
But anyway,
I learned a what it is,
I was 42 at the time and uh,
that made a lot of sense to
me. So it's craigslist, um,
just kept plugging away for a
few years all by myself. Uh,
one interesting thing in
97 was that people at job
posters ask me to charge them
for their ads. Why? Um,
they thought they were getting
better results in the list. Um,
but a better results than paying expensive
headhunters or whatever for it to
help them get people.
So I figured I w a philosophy
might be to charge people for ads,
people who already paid for ads,
but to charge them a much less
money for more effective ads.
And that's a practice we continue to
this day. The side is almost all free,
but we do charge for ads specifically
at times to minimize abuse.
Like in New York apartment
brokers in Manhattan,
the New York apartment brokers can really,
uh,
damaged people like at
the very last minute,
they'll tell you if there's
a big commission on an
apartment and that's not okay.
And speaking to them,
we made a little dent in the problem,
but I'm getting way ahead of
myself. And in 97 also, uh,
at that point we were hitting or I was
hitting about a million page views per
month,
which at the end of 97 for a one
person operation pretty good.
And,
uh,
also Microsoft sidewalk and obsolete
city site wanted to run banner ads,
but I disliked banner ads.
I,
many of them I think are just kind
of stupid. So I just decided that,
uh, you know, I'm living
comfortably enough.
I don't need the extra
income that grew into a,
the lesson that, uh, but
I was calling nerd values.
If you make enough money to live
comfortably and then to help your family,
maybe some friends live comfortably,
then it's more satisfying
to change the world.
And that's our philosophy
to date. But are I, uh,
people are also suggesting that I
ran the site on a volunteer basis.
That's what happened in 98.
Uh,
[inaudible] even back then,
things were easy.
I recently saw a credit card bill
from back then and I was running and
craigslist on something
called best Internet services,
which is all gone now. But I
was running the site, the name,
well sorry, best internist. Yeah,
they got bought by someone who was
bought by someone else. And uh,
but I was paying 35 bucks a month for
hosting services back then and it,
cause sometime in that timeframe,
well before I get,
before I used the services of
volunteers, I was thinking, well,
I'm using pine. I one point realized, oh,
pine can output and email into a,
a perl script.
Pearl was hot then.
And, uh, I figured, well,
I can write some simple code
which extracts the email
headers because they were
pretty predictable and I
would have instant html pages,
therefore instant publishing.
And that's how our site was born.
I think that was late 96,
but I don't remember because this was
all a hobby and I wasn't taking notes.
So on 98 rolls around,
I try writing things from a,
with volunteers and there
to say a lot in a few words,
people, some of the job
posters who wanted to pay me,
who started off that like a year before
they approached me and said things were
not working and they said if I
wanted to craigslist and survive,
I had to go full time, make it
into a real company. And uh,
they were right.
Um,
99 I had to make tough decisions
like how much to monetize.
And again, I was thinking, you
know, that nerd values thing.
And I was thinking even
from Sunday school,
Mr and Mrs [inaudible] taught me,
you know,
to think how much is enough.
And in my case,
not too much is enough.
I do indulge myself in some ways.
I buy all the books I want
and things like that. But,
uh,
you know,
I don't go crazy with things and I just
gave up my old Prius 15 years old to a
brother in law who has three,
uh, kids who are driving now.
You know,
I have a feeling I may wind up regretting
my decision and I have my eye on the
Chevy Bolt, which is a good electric car
and it has a lot of electronics on it,
which I could fool around with
and possibly injure myself.
So they are, I am, you know,
uh, these guys say I should,
uh, start a new, you know,
start my own company and by then
even add lots of parties and stuff.
I talked to a bankers and, uh, you know,
vcs in this area and they are
telling me, hey, I should, uh,
monetize the usual silicon valley way
and there will be putting billions of
dollars on the table.
The answer again is how much do you need?
Like, now that I've done
a lot with philanthropy,
I can see having a some billions
to give away. It'd be pretty cool.
But I also think about the philanthropic
model of the robber barons who would
acquire the equivalent of billions.
They would acquire it by abusing their
employees and their customers and then
they would give back a little bit of it,
you know,
decades after the fact.
So instead, I'm thinking,
but craigslist is about,
is helping people put food on the table.
It's helping people find a
table under which to put on the,
on which to put the food.
And then Craig's list is about finding
a roof under which to put the table with
the food.
And so there's this a philanthropic
model I've accidentally come up with,
which is let someone trying
to put food on the table,
keep the money they would
otherwise spend on advertising.
And that's a much more cost efficient,
a model for philanthropy and
so said and fewest words.
The business model is
doing well by doing good.
And that worked out pretty well.
Uh,
I tried running the company myself for
about a year and then some of the same
people approached me and help me
understand that as a manager I suck.
Um,
I'm emotionally unsuited
to the hardest of,
uh, management activities
like hiring and firing people.
I'm just not tough. Hired a Jim
[inaudible], Jim Buckmaster to do the job.
Uh, that's worked. And, uh,
I figured around then I
stopped programming because,
you know, at 10 point around then we
had hired a whole cadre of programmers,
all of whom smarter than me,
but I saw a need for myself to go full
time in customer service because another
Sunday school lesson was treated.
People like you wanted to be treated.
And in business that means have serious
customer service and you do the best you
can. It's challenging when
your site is mostly free.
And that's probably an unsolvable
problem in some regards.
But that's what we, uh,
that's what we were trying.
And uh,
it turns it over to Jim did customer
service for a long time thing is in
customer service online.
You may have heard that, uh,
you see some things that you
can never unsee. You know,
I have seen a certain amount of
ugliness I've seen far more good,
but the ugliness can get to you.
And that's a big problem right now in
user generated content and in commenting
systems,
there is a great need for keyword or
keyword filtering kind of systems.
That is actually this word filtering
systems that can figure out bad stuff,
um,
in ways that doesn't rely on actually
seeing specific keywords or doing basian
filtering.
What's needed is software,
which I don't think exists because I
don't think AI juristics we'll solve that
problem. Um, if anyone knows him or
anything like that, I'd like to know.
But, uh, um, I have a feeling
the only thing I could do,
the full customer service job
would be actual strong AI.
And I for one, welcome our
machine overlords. Frankly,
I'm beginning to feel like it's time for
machine overlords. And when I say that,
I'm not sure if I'm joking anymore.
So that was a,
you know,
2000 and since then
Craig's list just grows.
We're now in a whole bunch of more
cities, a whole bunch more countries. Uh,
the direction I, uh, put it in
generally remains unchanged.
Uh, folks may hear, may have noticed
that we have changed the user experience,
but stay consistent with design principles
which say keep it simple and keep it
fast. Listen to what are the
real needs and wants of people,
not the fancy stuff.
So you'll see that in
our tables of contents,
which are used to be things you scanned.
There is fairly sophisticated
database powering there. And uh,
there's uh,
you know,
you'll be able to see thumbnails of the
pictures which are in the things you'll
be able to see. The whole picture is, uh,
you'll be able to see maps
and all the variants of that.
Is he the last programming
thing that I did? 99 or 2000?
I don't remember when was, well back
then I remember I was using pine,
the Dataset,
the database for craigslist
back then was time,
email folders. So, and pine is great.
Pine forgive me in many respects,
as much easier to use in Gmail.
This is actually a,
forgive me for bringing up the name.
I had an extensive discussion on this
with Marissa Meyer about 10 years ago,
which is why there are some shortcuts
in Gmail. But the deal is that, uh,
I was able to with a few commands to
identify and remove all the old ads in a
category with pine.
And when pine email folders started
proving to be a unsatisfactory,
I switched to my SQL and
that's when I stopped coding.
Now and for the last several
years, I do some, uh,
what I call lightweight or token customer
service to stay in touch with what's
real because you want to find out
what's going on with everything,
what do people care about,
what matters to people.
And so I get to do that.
Sometimes I handle a customer service
email directly and also very frequently
people will find me and social media
and, uh, come up with requests,
which I'm embarrassed to say
I can't really help with. Um,
so what I do with those is
I generally, uh, just uh,
share them with a main
line customer service.
And I have to phrase it carefully because
the Yahoo versus Barnes case makes it
very clear that you can't imply you're
going to solve a problem and you know,
not, you know, and if you,
if it slips between the cracks
or you just forget or whatever,
you have a problem.
So that's craigslist.
They're doing well by doing good.
And again,
I made that decision to
monetize minimally in a 99,
2000,
not altruistically,
but it's just what feels right.
Speaking as a nerd,
as a person who is genuinely
dysfunctional in these regards,
uh,
that's what happens sometimes.
But in the last 10 plus years,
over those years,
people from nonprofit organizations
were coming to me talking about how to,
uh, how to build community,
how to run sites,
which might be the craigslist for
something. And frankly too, they,
at times they were hoping for
a cash contributions and so on.
And I started getting
organized regarding that.
In 2011 it was something
called Craig connects.
And as branding that kind of sucks
and it just didn't work very well.
I'm pretty, uh, I'm more organized now
and I have this thing, Craig Newmark,
philanthropy's dot org which
consist of Craig Newmark foundation,
which is a five o one c three and I
have a couple of donor advised funds.
There's also the craigslist charitable
fund. The idea is that I figure,
um, I could see what's going on in the
world today and I can identify some areas
where help is needed and uh,
you know,
where I can help other people,
I can find smart people who are doing
things that make a difference and support
them with media, with
cash, with convening power.
Uh,
the deal is that I screwed up really
badly with craigslist in the sense that I
haven't,
I never told people back in 2000 and
not now that I'm not in craigslist
management and I've had real no real
role to play in any decision making since
2000 stupid of me.
And I learned how stupid that
was around 2010. So since then,
I've now gotten communications
and PR religion.
I'm a zealot that matters for technical
people because every one of us,
how about us? Our own image, our
own brand, our own narrative.
And no one is going to really
watch out for your own narrative.
That's something as tech people
we're all responsible for.
But I figured that out in 2010 God,
professional help and the right now I
need a great deal of professional help and
I have it. I got an email from some of
the folks right before coming up here,
literally. So that's a big,
big lesson. But in a way,
with the help of
professional communicators,
I've identified four areas
where I'm helping people.
There's a veterans and their families
because I figure if someone's willing to
maybe go to another country and
risk taking ability protecting me,
I should do something.
And it never occurred to me until I was
told that their families give up and
sacrifice a lot for them.
So for example,
I started off today working with
the Bob Woodruff Foundation.
They find they qualify and vet and fund
organizations which support wounded
veterans, wounded veterans and
their families and their caregivers.
So this is a really good setup.
We got going and literally that was nine
o'clock this morning that I met with
him.
Um,
another area in the interest of practicing
what you preach and treating people
like you want to be treated.
I have a women in tech effort,
which I'm still developing.
Uh,
I've been involved for years with
the women's startup challenge,
which is a deal where,
um,
startups run by women pitch to a panel
of vcs winning valuable cash prizes and
winning valuable time with vcs cause
still usually hang around and help you
network and give you advice.
So that's a big deal, um,
in this year or two. But if you
want to protect the country, um,
voting rights,
the voting rights of lots of people
in this country are under attack.
We knew they were under attack by bad
politicians for some years because
sometimes the politicians will
admit it sometimes in a row,
a week or so ago in a document
produced by Robert Muller in part 47,
he says that one thing the Russians
were doing was interfering with,
uh,
people actually voting.
They were going after people who might
vote democratic and that may have tilted
things in some states. Notice I'm not
making a political statement there.
I'm talking about protecting the country,
so the deal is that I'm doing what I can
to protect voting rights that's still
developing because I'm only now
talking to the people doing it.
Most of all though I have
a program involved with
trustworthy journalism and I'm
supporting a number of groups
that are trying to do good work.
Like I'm working with the
Google newspeople to support
the trust project out of
Santa Clara University.
Speaking as a news consumer,
I just want news I can trust the trust
project is one way of articulating what a
news outlet has to do to
provide trustworthy news.
Things like don't lie to people.
Things like when you do make a mistake,
fix it.
Things like listen to different
kinds of people so you get different
perspectives.
There's other things involved to Poynter
institute runs the international fact
checking network because of a news
outlet commits to trustworthy journalism.
They should, you know, you need watchdogs
to make sure that they're doing it.
But as of a year ago,
one guy who actually has been here and
who talks with the Google newspaper a lot,
and also Facebook guy named Jeff Jarvis
a year ago told me for fun to read the
NATO handbook on Russian information
warfare in that Russian military and
military intelligence particular tell us,
tell the world what they're gonna
do to the u s during the election.
Uh,
and uh,
last week I think Canadian
intelligence among others says,
hey,
here's what the Russians did in 2016
and continue to do now get growing up in
the 50s, I saw a lot of crackpot activity
regarding communists and Russians.
And so I'm a very gun shy in this regards,
but,
um, the intelligence
community and, uh, you know,
the people investigating fake news,
the people who are looking at
networks of it say a lot of,
there's a lot of domestic bad actors
amplifying what the Russians are doing for
really bad results, including a lot
of harassment. This is real stuff.
And I figure if I want to
help defend the country,
I need to find people,
do find people doing good work.
I need to get them communication
support and I need to fund them.
And honestly,
I'm now writing large checks to
support these groups because, uh,
they are defending the country just like
active service members and veterans and
their families help defend the country.
Similarly,
I think Wikipedia plays a big role in
this because my slogan about Wikipedia is
that Wikipedia is where facts go to live.
So I'm involved in helping fund
their counter arrestment effort.
I'm talking to them about, uh, what's
the nature of reliable sources.
And,
uh,
I'm also working with him on the bio's
of living persons because it's just
really hard to get those bios fixed.
I had a college professor,
uh,
fixed mine up for the most part,
but I've been into some events recently
where when I talk about Wikipedia,
frankly I get a lot of crap from
notable people who have Vyos,
who have no way of fixing them.
So those are the kinds of things.
I'm a working with Wikipedia.
I am a PR one of the
funders of Wiki Tribune. Uh,
but that's not a Wikipedia thing.
Although oddly last week
in Miami at a conference,
I saw Jimmy plus a or reach who are
the cofounders of Reiki Tribune.
So the deal here is on
the craigslist side,
a business model of doing well by doing
good with a lot of luck can do pretty
well. And I feel I, uh, well if you may,
if you're lucky enough to do well,
you should help the next people do well
and you should practice what you preach,
which includes, um, treating people
like he wanted to be treated.
I can go on quite a long time,
but I'm going to stop there.
Thank you very much.
Um,
I think you've mentioned that in 2011
that you started to come to crack next and
in 2015 you decided to launch the crack.
You Mark Foundation,
even based on the name,
I think are quite different approaches
behind dad's message. Right?
So,
uh,
you're making a correct inference
regarding the names. It just,
it didn't work out that way.
Um,
I remember 2011 I wanted to have a brand
that would be catchy and effective.
The best we could think of a cracker next
just failed because no one knows what
Craig is. Craig Newmark foundation
or Craig Newmark philanthropies.
People know what that is.
And interestingly,
I hear rumors that people in New York
may know more about who Craig Newmark is.
Then in the bay area,
the advantage there is that New
York is the country's hub of news,
media and influence and connection.
This isn't it.
And what I want to do are things that
contribute as I pushed my efforts,
I want to contribute towards a new
normal of trustworthy news and that means
things that I do have to
be noticed to be effective.
I think we are
in about,
it's about,
we have about 20 minutes
left and then we can um,
have some questions
that was from the dory.
And also you're more than
welcome to use that mic for, uh,
for life questions says,
well,
I can ask a question that
was from Googlers RSVP.
One of them is,
uh,
I haven't been using CEO at least for
at least 10 years and cannot pass it up
the moment to thank you for making a
huge impact to every day Americans like
myself.
The question is what inspire you to be
able to crack list in the first place?
Uh,
it literally is just the,
uh,
the sense that I should give back because
on the well and using it newsgroups
even back in the early nineties,
I was told the craziness,
there were still a lot of people
who would help each other out,
sometimes contributing
expensive consulting time.
There were a couple of dramatic
cases on the, well, we're a doctor,
help save people.
So that's it.
The idea is that I'm getting such good
stuff from this community I should give
back.
And it felt right,
but why was it very difficult to get?
Because at the time there was not
much of that services, right? Uh,
even 250 of the subscribers at
the time who were appropriate,
but using maybe phone lines
and modems to dial. Right.
If you think about that has quite
difficult. What, what's the, uh,
the biggest challenge in the
early earliest days? Yeah,
I think I started by the way,
with the 9,696 scoreboard modem or 9.6
kilowatt modem and I remember when 56 was
a big deal. Um, but uh,
can you repeat that again?
What was your biggest
challenge in the earliest days
challenge in terms of growing?
Well,
the good part was I wasn't thinking
about growing things grew word of mouth.
If someone at a company
was getting the mailings,
they would share it with other people
in the same company and then that person
would send me an email saying,
put me on the email list.
That worked pretty well.
Something that helped accelerate this
was that this was a 95 when the Dotcom
boom was just hitting San Francisco.
And uh,
that accelerated things,
a phenomenon back there.
I've got like lots of launch
parties, some open, some closed. Uh,
Patty Baran did something called SF girl.
Her specialty was finding launch parties
and telling people how to get into them
even if they were closed.
My only distinct memory from that time
was that the, uh, new at that time,
San Francisco Museum of
Modern Art in the entry,
they had lots of food and they
were a big mounds of fresh shrimp.
And that was my favorite memory
of that, uh, of that era.
It was people were spending way too much
money on this kind of thing. You know,
if you watch HBO, Silicon Valley,
you'll see a lot of the, uh,
that history being recapitulated.
Okay. Oh, take one,
a live question. Thank you for
joining us today. Um, there's so many,
Geez, globally. Um, do you
have things like, Fred,
this is a great for you moved to
the city and I need a free coach.
And for the most people that done one
already, is there other things like, uh,
that you're looking at advice,
um,
Aye
and frustrated in that I'm
not smart enough to think
of really good things to do.
What I have done at, partly through
a charity called in Venio in this,
in San Francisco,
is to help get refugee centers and so
on and related efforts wired up for the
Internet because the aid workers say
that they need internet connectivity for
various purposes. For example, in
that we did that in a Haiti that is,
I helped by funding in Haiti.
Uh,
and just yesterday I was reminded that
I helped get wired up the, the dob,
um,
refugee camp,
which may be the largest in the world
and I think it's in northern Africa
someplace.
I'd forgotten all about it until I saw a
reference because of the keyword search
in Google news yesterday and again,
literally yesterday.
Um,
there's been all other ones too when
the Obama administration was trying a
serious outreach to the Islamic world,
I helped wire up the vocational
schools in the West Bank.
Now we have something going
on a island in Lake Victoria.
We are there, we're helping
provide internet conductivity.
But there it's because people need it,
but it's also a lure into a
facility to get people tested,
tested for HIV because
culturally speaking,
it's really hard to get
people to get tested, but they
all want to be on the net.
So those are small things.
Nowadays I'm thinking I'm specializing
because in our country maybe we have an
all hands on deck situation where
things have gotten bad and we need to do
something good like protecting the vote,
like a stopping a bad actors,
Russians or otherwise from contaminating
the news because you really can't run a
democracy if the normal national
conversation has a lot of lying going on.
Thank you.
And we have another question from Dory.
Uh,
I think this is related to orient to
related to, um, the involvement of, uh,
of the, of the management.
But the question is,
I can think of many ways the crack glass
can improve and wondering what's the
roadmap and why does crack less seems
reluctant to take it to the next level.
Um, well for any of that since
I'm not involved in management,
email something to jim@craigslist.org.
Don't send any intellectual
property and uh,
hopefully you've gotten the lecture about
protecting that if not hear from the
folks on Hbo, Silicon Valley. Um,
so please do that.
Bear in mind,
that's what people seem to need is
not fancy stuff but effective stuff.
Fast and simple is always
big regarding the next level.
I don't know what the next level is,
but if you're helping people put food
on the table, that's pretty good.
Next level to me.
Right.
I asked me actually think of a
followup question on that. Like, um,
in terms of funding in from
the funder Craiglist uh,
you have been very conservative in
turning down and turned out a lot of
investment ask. Right? Uh,
and have you ever wondering that
with more resource like money,
that quick list would be able to have
more resources in fighting like scams and
spams.
And this also really applies to not just
craigslist but also maybe we compete
here and when, and maybe the
of the overall news community,
maybe,
uh,
what we need is a crush project to
Manhattan project in terms of the software
which can figure out that intent on
the part of a posting of any sort.
A posting could be an ad or a comment.
Um,
that would be really,
really smart software.
I don't think it exists and I don't
think it's going to exist anytime soon.
Maybe I should, uh, offer a
really big price for that.
And maybe that would be a,
maybe that would be a useful since
I don't think it exists. Yeah.
But we do, uh, we do needs
that, that kind of thing. Um,
there are, again, those are those people
who think software that smart, uh,
could achieve self awareness and you know,
you hope it's the nice
kind of self awareness.
Like the like the AI is that we in banks
culture novels and not the murderous
pistol wielding robots of Westworld.
Although that is a really good show.
Thank you.
We have another light questions.
I thank you for being here and sharing
our story and you appreciate it.
You seem like a really humble person, but
I last us anyways. When you look back,
what is the biggest you think you
did and what did you learn from it?
Our big,
well,
the big mistake as a company was not
seizing control and determining our own
narrative.
When you're not telling your own story,
other people can tell it and most
of them will be good, some are bad,
some of them will be running scams of one
sort or another. That's why on a, yeah,
in 2010 I started doing it for myself
and I've stumbled along the way,
but now I have a really
good from helping me out.
The thing is that you do need
good smart people doing that.
I like Marc Benioff at salesforce
does a great job of it.
There are other dotcoms who've
done a terrible job of it.
Even when people like me are trying to
help them and to try to do a little wake
up call
free to ask a live question.
Um,
I was wondering if you had any advice
in general around creating the Internet,
why communities?
Like how would you handle that scale
of people or what advice you'd give to
companies or startups or nonprofits
trying to create Internet scale?
Uh,
I don't have broad overall, uh, oh,
a advice just to watch out
that user generated content.
We'll have a moderation problem and there
was a number of unsolved problems with
it.
Yeah.
And right now that's in major flux
right now, somewhere in the alphabet.
There's a jigsaw,
I think that's Jared a Cohen.
I keep forgetting his last name.
Working directly with Eric Schmidt.
They think they have a handle
on the problem. I don't know.
But uh,
that's something which is badly needed.
There are folks who are doing a big
work with machine learning here and that
may, that may lead the
path. But again, uh,
um,
no one knows how were machine learning
is going to lead us and I am kind of
excited about it.
But remember,
I've been reading science
fiction for over 50 years.
How about I put the question
on the other way. Uh,
so you had been a nerd and the,
the credit list is actually a
very successful community, right?
If we want to learn from how to create
a white can come internet community,
what are things that were not coding
or technical but the things that you've
done,
what are the practices and strategy in
the early days that you think is part of
the success of this
creating this community?
Um,
the success factor is doing one's best
to provide a customer service that's
serious. Again, the challenge when
you're saying it's mostly free,
um,
that was the big thing right there because
the initial spirit that this site was
about giving people a break,
uh,
and people see that by accident,
that proved to be a good start,
a good initial culture or where as people
like to say it's in our DNA and that's
managed to succeed.
Is there any challenge to
work with volunteers with
volunteers in the early ages?
Oh,
thank you.
You mentioned a lot of them are volunteers
in that first year as a volunteer
thing failed because you can't,
uh,
you can't tell a volunteer to like,
do you think you just can't tell them
that their job depends on getting
something done at a certain time?
Because if they're volunteers,
you can't withdraw their pay.
So companies,
I guess the company in human history is
quite an invention to make things work
that otherwise I wouldn't work. So, uh,
you normally don't think
of it as an invention,
but it is and he is that and it is an
invention of the way how people can
collaborate. Right. Yeah. Yeah. That's
taken nother, uh, life questions.
Thanks for coming here. Um,
again, very, uh, interested in,
in your story and that was really
good to hear from you. Um, my,
I guess my question is,
you know,
you mentioned that people
come to you and to say,
do you have advice for creating
the craigslist? Oh Huh. Um,
I do find the fundamental
principle of Craig's list as a,
as a product very interesting,
which is connecting people who need
things with connecting people who want
things in a single place of exchange,
right? In a very fundamental level.
Like maybe airbnb is even trying
to do that, which is, you know,
I have some leftover things and if some
people can pay me for some of these
things, I'm curious to know for
all the ones that you heard,
can I create a Craig list of whatever?
What are the,
some of the most interesting things?
What are some of the most
successful things or even weirder?
Uh,
I don't pay much attention to the people
who make businesses out of that because
I, yeah, I guess I just
don't care. I mean,
that's a distraction. The
best kind of things, uh,
where people manage to make it a little
business out of finding junk stuff and
then rebuilding it and making it
into something real. And until today,
I couldn't think of a good example,
except again, I just gave a,
I was on a panel at Sanford business
school are a kid who must've been 20,
but look 14 to me,
but he made a business out of going
to the junk yards in his neighborhood.
Um, finding old bikes, uh,
rebuilding them and selling them.
And that,
uh,
was a way that he saved up
enough for whatever he needed.
Maybe a little bit for a
college or something like
that. That feels really good.
And there's been other things too because
during the recession, around 2008,
2009,
I could see a lot of people
who really were lying on a,
our site for advertising.
They were relying on it for barter because
sometimes that's the only way you're
going to get what you need in a recession.
And a,
that lasted a couple of years I
think. So we have all these, uh,
things happen that does feel pretty good.
But meanwhile,
in these philanthropic areas I
have, we have real challenges. Um,
again on Craig Newmark, freelance
reason.org. That's how I'm a Ho.
That's sound getting this, uh, uh,
this stuff done the best I can.
I should mention that I'm not restricting
myself completely to those sick,
those four areas. I'm working
with some groups on food security,
like a meals on wheels kinds of things,
delivering hot food to people or whatever.
Like in New York in particular,
I support God's love we deliver,
which when you say it fast
is God's lovely liver. Um,
and I also support a pigeon rescue
because I know how important that is to
everyone.
I've also learned there that pigeon
pants is a thing and that you want the
pigeon to be wearing the pants
before they fly onto your shoulder.
Two cool.
Lovingly at you.
If they do first and then
the pants are put on,
you may have a problem.
And I did,
although I do like pigeons a lot.
We have some question from the dory again,
I think the live streaming people
are now sending the questions.
One question is a Craiglist
has notoriously not modernized.
It's a design and Ux. What's
the reasoning afford this? Well,
I can't speak for the whole company,
but if you look at the site,
we've been incrementally making
improvements in it, uh, for years.
Both improvements that you
can see like the database,
like the thumbnail sketches and all
that and the people who use the site say
this is what they want. So we've
made a lot of improvements that way.
There's a lot of improvements
that you can't see,
like improved caching and
efforts to keep the site fast.
Speed is a design principle and it's
a really important design principle.
And yeah, Google does a lot
of things along those lines.
Like something I have to look into
is a better use of a Google domain,
a service.
Because I have my real doubts regarding
both my ISP that all three of my ISP
because something tells me their
DNS look ups are a kind of sluggish.
I should also count the hotel I usually
stay at in New York because their ISP
kind of, uh, fails to deliver.
But I'm hoping not to be in
there much longer. You, uh,
I have a question that daddy is
the integration of a blockchain.
The questions says, I'm
personally really, uh,
appreciate Wikipedia and crack and list
as the three layers of knowledge and
marketing information in the economy.
Have you considered blockchain
integration in which you could create pure
decentralized Craiglist
and token nomics around it,
but what's your view in general on that
and how can people can collaborate?
So a blockchain is applied to
the craigslist. I just saw mill,
which was working on,
what I'm thinking is that blockchain based
identity verified identity might be a
way that we can get a lot more
accountability on the net.
And like when you get a scam
sent to you or a piece of spam,
you'd like to hold the center a
carnival to that, that's good.
But on the net,
we're always going to need places
where you can be completely anonymous,
places for dissidents, whistleblowers, uh,
people who may be in a really
bad domestic abuse situation.
We're always going to need places
where verified identity is not good.
We're in anonymity is good. Uh, this
may also apply, and this is a big thing.
The European Union now has this
GDPR standard. Uh, it's, uh,
a set of standards which allow consumers
to control the data passed between
publishers and advertisers.
And, uh, my gut,
my gut feeling is that blockchain based
to control of an individual's data will
be away to make everyone happy in terms
of the data about a consumer that a
advertiser and publisher can chair.
Cause I don't know about you,
but I want control of that,
that kind of data.
And I do want to be served ads,
which actually means something to me.
You know, sometimes it's mixed
because my wife and they are shit.
My wife and I share an Amazon account,
especially when she's buying things for
the nephews and nieces and we've got 21
of them. So odd things up in my, uh,
in my Amazon profile.
That's okay.
But I want the ability to control that
blockchain may be the way to do that.
And do you think it also may help
in turn and stuff that say, um,
uh, the chew news and uh, uh,
fighting the fake news thing,
for example? I don't know honestly
what role they play in that.
That's something that people
smarter than me are working on. Um,
my gut tells me that,
uh,
like one of the biggest things that need
to happen are the fact checkers. Uh,
I like at the international fact checking
network and the tech and check people
let Duke they like if you,
if fact checking in real time is really
hard because if someone lies to the,
um, and the newspapers and so
on and report it, you know, it,
they may only realized that
it's a lie an hour after.
So we're talking about
summary fact checking,
meaning that a person or a news outlet
will have a track record in terms of how
honest they are not. And I think
that's going to need a lot of, uh,
that's gonna need a lot of
work because frankly, um,
it's not hard to figure out what news
outlets try to get things right and which
news outlets deliberately
get things wrong.
The idea is how do you do it so that no
one is an arbiter of truth is no one,
no single group or anything.
We'll arbitrary truth.
Instead you have a large network of
networks and that's what's happening right
now. Maybe not fast enough. And I, uh,
just realize another condition
I made put on if I may make,
and I'm going to make a very large
grant to a particular news, uh,
institution because,
you know,
I'm talking about journalism, but I'm
a news consumer and I've learned a lot.
But unless you've been writing to get
to deadline like five times a week,
you don't know journalism because
that's really a tough kind of creative
pressure. You know, I've,
I've been in situations where I've
had to write code to deadline,
but writing stories that deadline is
tougher because you don't know what the
story is at a time.
Whereas if you're coding,
you normally know what kind
of stuff you got to write.
Presumably someone's done
some decent requirements,
definition of the variety,
which is not entirely stupid.
I put that qualification on,
uh,
just reminding people that I worked
in IBM development for six years.
Not that I have anything specific in
mind. Okay. One of the last question.
Uh,
we saw the startup train of pursuing
vertical opportunities of Wa cracking list
is doing for the past decade
as a horizontal company.
I'm wondering what crack list think of
this trend and how crack when we respond
to this trend of the future?
Uh,
I don't think about it much because
I'm focused on philanthropy. Uh,
Jim may be thinking about it,
but you'd have to ask him,
which is not a satisfactory answer.
But again, the deal is that,
and may it's may be a good thing
that like for roughly 10 years,
um, I focused well for, for
10 years I focused on coding,
then customer service.
Then for a lot of that I focused on
customer service and then philanthropy.
Not that I'm a really, really smart in
any of that, but I'm combining the two.
I mean,
I've been lucky enough to do well and
I'm putting my money where my mouth is in
all this. The deal is that, uh, you know,
there's this billionaire's pledge to
give away half of what you've made during
your lifetime. I have a
friend, I'm not being specific,
but I've already exceeded that. I'm, uh,
looking to do more to do
it in smart ways because a,
a democracy cannot survive
built on lies and you know,
we need to fix that and we have some
runway to fix that until things go really
bad. So I'm involved in that kind
of thing. And by but involved,
I mean,
I'm involved in it
literally every day and uh,
you know, that ain't so bad. Again,
there's a lot of people around who are
smarter than me and who do more than me.
My role is to, uh, bring them
together and to get some cash to him.
Not Bad.
Thank you.
I liked thank Craig you mark for being
here and have the conversation with us
and I would like to thank the crew and
all the audience here and young and
livestreaming. Thank you for
being here and please follow up.
Ghostlight Wikipedians are for
future events. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.